and in Washington the Supreme Court is
taking more time to decide if the
abortion pill mifipristone should remain
available Nationwide the White House is
appealing Lower Court lower court
rulings rather including one from a
judge who said the drug had been wrongly
approved Jan Crawford is at the Supreme
Court with more on this story Jan good
morning to you
good morning gal you know we'd expect
you to know this morning whether the
court was going to kind of indefinitely
block those lower court rulings but
without any explanation the justices
have pushed that deadline back until
tomorrow night
just hours before Wednesday's deadline
Justice Samuel Alito announced an
extension which keeps the abortion pill
mifepristone available Nationwide for at
least two more days
the Biden Administration and drug
manufacturer have asked the justices to
step in or block lower court rulings
that would ban or greatly restrict the
pill which is used in more than half of
abortions in the U.S all of this is
unusual from top to bottom CBS News
legal contributor Jessica Levinson says
it's uncommon for the justices to push
their own self-imposed deadline we don't
know if it's they're so close to being
able to have a unanimous agreement and
they want to be able to get there or if
there's just such a huge breakdown that
there are really aggressive majority
opinion and a really aggressive descent
well the court is not currently
considering the merits of the case it
will determine if women continue to have
access to the drug while cases work
their way through the courts the
American Medical Association says recent
rulings could undermine FDA approvals of
other drugs we just think it's
incredibly Reckless to upend our entire
drug approval system in this country and
create chaos where we're going to have
individual courts in states around the
country
basically undoing those decisions some
republicans in Congress say that concern
is overblown now this isn't related to
regulation drugs this is related to a
federal bureaucracy following the rule
of law but the White House says it's
ready for a battle in the courts we are
prepared for any outcome the Supreme
Court May issue and we are prepared for
a long legal fight if necessary
and it probably will be a long legal
fight because even if the justices put
these rulings on hold the case is going
to kind of continue to work its way
through the lower courts and there are
other challenges in other states so
either way the issue of abortion is
going to end up right back here before
these justices Nate
Jan thank you